Oh coffee on a Tuesday in block 19 the
Paul J Getty Museum in Los Angeles is
beautiful not only for the breathtaking
artifacts in its large collection but
for the palatial architecture and for
the experience of going there to the top
of that mountain in a trolley car above
the city from some of its balconies you
can see the entirety of Greater Los
Angeles sat beneath its film of smog and
you can see the ocean and the West its
gardens are tranquil you can sit on the
grass and enjoy the day and then it's
back down the trolley and you feel
educated cultured better for the
experience the next morning over coffee
you read in the paper that
archaeological sites in Iraq have been
ravaged by looters who have sunk holes
into the dirt and ripped thousands of
year old artifacts from the ground to
sell them on the market for cash still
fresh from your trip to the Getty your
newfound sense of culture is outraged by
such disregard for history and you begin
to think of those artifacts you saw
yesterday in the museum as the luckiest
orphans in the world thank God for
museums you say thank God for the Getty
here is the essential problem of the
antiquities market on the one side you
have looters who everybody hates and on
the other side you have museums which
everybody loves it's hard to see at
first glance that these two things are
unavoidably connected see looters Luke
because there's money in it these are
poor people and they need to feed their
families ok so let's say that it
circulates around the village that there
is a man in town willing to pay good
money for Sumerian cylinder seals from
the Babylonian era and the guy next door
knows exactly where to find them well
our would-be looter
travels with his neighbor in the middle
of the night to the chosen
archaeological site and sinks holes into
the ground looking for Sumerian cylinder
seals he doesn't find anything for a
while eventually he comes upon a pocket
of them now his shovel has smashed 5
beyond all recognition but two are still
intact even in good condition and this
will feed his family for a month so he
goes to town and seeks the buyer out now
he pays a little bit less than was
reported but beggars can't be choosers
and this is his first time now the buyer
is excited because these cylinder seals
are there
hot right now among private collectors
and he expects a good turnover from here
the cylinder seals run a complicated
route of buyers and sellers and
smugglers and dealers across oceans and
international borders maybe staying a
while in the Geneva Freeport where
storage items are exempt from customs
regulations you know just to keep a low
profile it's an almost impossible route
to follow an antiquities dealers are
very good at confusing the authorities
who mostly stay five steps behind and
out of Georgia eventually those very
very old Sumerian cylinder seals will
end up in one of two places private
collections or museums why well because
like I said those seals are very hot
right now and in an estimated 4 billion
dollar-a-year industry
hot is really yes the dealers fooled the
authorities but it's small potatoes when
you consider how much they fooled us see
the whole thing can be boiled down to a
simple business model supply and demand
without demand there is no supply and so
museums like the Getty in Los Angeles or
the Met in New York City or the MFA in
Boston can go on demanding it elicits
artifacts because most people don't
realize that this causes this it's why
when people like Philippe de Montebello
the former director of the Mets say
things like would archeologists abandon
a shivering orphaned child on a cold
rainy day in the stream defense of their
practices we can call a big [ __ ]
these people are the parents orphanage
their children off the metaphor is
irrelevant
it was Montebello in 2006 who had to
return the famed knew from his crater to
Italy after it was shown to have have
been clearly looted from a tomb in
cerveteri he later said how much more
could you learn from knowing which
particular hole that came out of well
this just shows you how ignorant these
people really are as the answer to his
question is of course virtually every
there's an archaeological term called
provenience it means the location of an
object in three-dimensional space in
relation to all the things around it
another word would be contexts and
objects provenience tells us 99% of the
information about its significance and
use it's why archaeologists use all
those little tools to dig things up to
preserve the provenience ok so an
example if a Roman coin was found by
snorkelers off the coast of Alexandria
and sold to museum the experts there
would probably tell you a lot about what
year it was made and what minted came
from even and that's a nice amount of
superficial information let's say the
circular didn't touch the coin and
instead reported the fine
well archeologist searching the area
then fine
many more coins and not only can they
tell you about the year that it was made
in the mint that it came from but they
could start to tell you a new story
about the shipping trade in the Roman
era Mediterranean Sea context is
everything
the aim of archeology is to tell the
most true most comprehensive story about
the past under the assumption that both
the past and the truth are worth
something too in 2007 the Getty returned
40 artifacts to Italy under mounting
pressure from international authorities
now they did it quietly and without
admitting wrongdoing but these
repatriations are becoming more con to
stop the supply you have to choke the
demand and to do that you have to
educate people about how the antiquities
market really works you have to show
them how they are being fooled by
palatial architecture and great
presentation you have to say to them
that though these places are undeniably
beautiful sitting as they do on the top
of mountains above the city that there
are cultures being destroyed and
forgotten every day and they have their
own ideas about architecture and
presentation and beauty and don't you
think that their ideas our culture has a
right to be remembered correctly hi
nerdwriter here this is my friend Sam he
just finished making a world war two
short epic called the American starring
me if you want to check it out and I
suggest that you do because it is pretty
[ __ ] awesome you can find that link
in the doobly-doo
anything to add Sam